hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the rake multiplayer
we got wait I was like so you guys
wanted to see more because in the last
episode we didn't fully take it
seriously and obviously with the start
of this episode we're taking it much
more seriously but we actually have an
objective and we got bobbing so hi Bob
hi so so Bob did you know there's a
monster in these woods that's why I had
the gun either I'm supposed to kill you
or kill the monster I'm not killing you
so we start to piss you off by the end
of this round you can yeah
also this one's way yeah you were aiming
like way over here on my screen so what
I'm what I'm pointing right at your face
right now but the gun on my screen is
pointed like three feet to the right of
the oh yeah Wow
that's true but the aiming reticles
right on your face right now okay all
right let me go grab cameras cuz we're
gonna need them here yeah I picked up
one of them I guess I'm the only one
with the shotguns so I might as well
have all of them yeah there's no rifle
that we're gonna get I believe there's
two of each guns somewhere on the map I
don't know where oh yeah there's a house
that you went to but we didn't go so
let's let's go through the woods and
make sure we go together and number
where we're going I don't explain
yes all right bear traps
hey if if the monster shows up I think
we should all react in the same place
okay
all right so good that was early yeah we
got it we got a wait I was gonna say I'm
starting to say I think our reaction
should be this if the rake shows up we
should be sure to do that okay wait I'll
be ready I'll be ready all right there's
bear traps up here that we can get to
trap him said that it doesn't do that
was it that was it that was a no okay
yeah
did you freak out like we planned
alright okay wait you have your bear
traps right yeah okay whoa what is that
oh I found a Peggy well finally I kill
it
No all right I was offered you go was
this the one with the other ones yeah
Bob yeah there's a tent over there
[ __ ] with me no whoa the music gap
the music seems way more intense than
the last time that I played where are
you guys
oh no no I'll [ __ ] you oh geez that
music tho oh he was there yeah I don't
think there are any more bear traps for
him okay Bob um our mark Bob let's go
this way okay I the house or the other
house of the waterfalls this direction
uh-huh [ __ ] thing no we're actually
this time but if we do at that time but
thought it was like an alien anal probe
lifting gravity beam I mean whatever
watch be baby yeah pretty much all right
so we're gonna hear there's so much
louder oh yeah this is the place
nothing oh yeah this oh this wasn't this
wasn't the cave that's right the cave is
to the left of year the actual cave all
right so wait where did someone's dreams
of us huh or the other person go what
what's the walk down already
oh I I went out oh yeah
the race got me all right if we go left
left is the other cave I'm pretty sure
I'm still fairly certain you guys you're
just [ __ ] with me no I mean I'm
usually better not this one time I'm
stuck on a tree that's not how this
works
yeah I don't know what's going on with
that me also I think it's this server
yeah problem happen again it did where
my guy just freaks out for no goddamn
reason I know like the pressure market
thank you it this is just a rock
formation but I'm hearing lots of tree
cookies yeah oh it's the ah yeah this is
what we're looking for
oh there we are oh hey Bob you had the
shotgun huh you lead the way I go home
Bob oh please you know what okay we
already led you with the only jumpscared
we do but I failed it into the second
one so man I kill slow I can't hear you
guys is it yeah it's pretty [ __ ]
laughter yeah no keep going forward Bob
you can help it nope oh yeah if it's
collapsing around booth okay this seems
like such a good place to be yeah you're
almost there Bob oh I'm almost there am
i yeah you are I'm almost to the thing
that you know it's gonna get me no I
meant the other side of the cave yeah
uh-huh
left or right
over to connect here okay it's not
really a fork what's that what's that oh
it's oh yeah we didn't explore over here
to the ripe I do know the the sniper
rifle still left right here yeah wait
you can have that one yeah girl
yeah I'll stick with the bat-trap yet
trees that hey buddy how's it going well
that seems good yep we're yeah you found
like a foot I'm so bad with this gun but
okay got it
yeah so there's a lot of that's a huge
leg yeah I know it's like as big as your
both of your legs put together yeah so
you can imagine if the rate killed this
thing I noticed something that's
definitely the end of a leg and a foot I
can tell with these binoculars oh thank
you man you're welcome you're a
lifesaver
I don't think be your end on the
keyboard you can plop binoculars be your
end then like left click holy [ __ ] oh
wait and that's B B Wow wait I can get a
real close look at your completely laid
alert out face oh yeah some night vision
- how do you turn that oh I mean it's
not really night vision this is you see
a little bit better if the flashlight
works in the distance as if it's being
projected to the origin of view for the
or the binoculars yeah it's an intended
feature working as intended I'm just
looking around an area there I don't
think there's a house but yeah
over here like another NPC with a
flashlight just like Earth dafuq what
whoa Jesus what happened
lots of tree crackling noise this time
someone jumped out of free yeah the
biggest sure you're nice and save it
there but I saw the door closing and
then as someone running away and I was
just like I'm gonna go venture out I'll
be back baby oh well hey we'll hey hump
wait and then ran away oh geez oh I
leave for one goddamn second you guys I
wanted to be so brave I just switch to
the camera and immediately all I hear is
stop stop stop stop stop
so if you leave the camper go to the
right just plug that right wall yeah I
got try to get back to the camper first
step Oh Bob's already inside hit a lot
of things I think there was another trap
jump scare in there ah no I just it's
fine hey there's another sniper rifle up
here I definitely had no idea damn where
are you guys back to the camp whoa
that is cool can we go down inside the
door alright doubt it
okay ah there's a
up here oh I'm taking it alright good
thing I just died so now I don't have to
worry about losing my health again yeah
there's no jump scares in here
yeah that's relief man god that's a very
normal-sized arm to go with the giant
foot we found I know who the guy just
had real big legs maybe not a mystery
legs he didn't skip leg day Hey oh wow
add sounds look at the rigs hell is that
just from running into trap oh yeah yeah
what an [ __ ] I mean eventually kill
himself you want to go back to camp and
just like why I don't know that's new
noises yeah that's weird
Oh watch the hill the hill okay I wanna
kill
Wow wait like this I think I got one
more one more shot in me what a game
holy [ __ ] it was fun but it wasn't
fun because the game was good yeah
that's the thing like it's fun because
of what you make of it
it was but because it's ridiculous the
open-world horror aspects really cool
but then jump scares are good that
happened but it just needs to be like a
whole game I mean it's in alpha right so
yeah eventually yeah eventually nine
months ago they quit working on it oh my
gosh oh well but imagine what this game
could have been had it left alpha zero
point zero point one that's a good way
to look at things so we'll end on that
note thanks guys so much for watching
check out Bob and Wade's channel in the
description below for more cool stuff
that we've done and thank you everybody
for watching and as always we'll see you
in
okay